obvia como para entender como el space
six se convirtió en un factor importante
en la carrera espacial tenemos que
remontarnos a los inicios de la estación
espacial internacional
[Música]
al principio todo estaba diseñado para
el programa de transbordadores de eeuu
las naves espaciales rusas soyuz eran
bienvenidas pero sólo tenían una quinta
parte de la capacidad de sus homólogas
estadounidenses
todo cambió el 1 de febrero de 2003
cuando el transbordador estadounidense
columbia explotó durante su regreso a la
tierra tras ello durante dos años y
medio los transbordadores se
suspendieron la estación espacial entró
en modo de supervivencia con suministros
limitados
el programa se convierte oficialmente
muy peligroso muy frágil y muy caro el
entonces presidente george w.bush
decidió detenerlo
en 2011 el transbordador fue retirado
del servicio y la nasa se puso a buscar
empresas que le proporcionarán un
reemplazo para llevar bienes y
astronautas a la estación espacial
internacional
[Música]
con su cápsula dragón y su cohete falcon
9 el space yx intervino y en mayo de
2012 la empresa de el on mars celebró su
primer vuelo a la estación desde
entonces el falcon 9 ha realizado 110
lanzamientos con éxito muy por encima de
sus competidores
de los 9 a ganador además fue el cohete
propulsor reutilizable que redujo
drásticamente los costos y aumentó los
lanzamientos como al principio todo el
mundo era ligeramente escéptico con
spacex progresivamente lo vimos al
recuperarse después era muy utilizado
hay un lanzador que se ha usado por
novena vez eso significa que van a
cumplir su objetivo de usar la misma
plataforma para por lo menos 10 misiones
la cápsula para el viaje de thomas
pesquet ya fue usada en un vuelo de
prueba el año pasado el lanzador se
ocupó en enviar un equipo anterior a la
estación gestiona un equipo al ver la
estación